hi I'm Kristen toll and I'm a director
in the microsoft research connections
team today I'm going to be telling you
about Microsoft translator hub Microsoft
translator hub was designed for use by
organizations that have specific
translation needs whether it is language
preservation or systems for specific
domains one of the differentiators of
Microsoft translator hub is that it
leverages our machine learning back-end
and the big translation models that ship
on being translator the translation
models are built on a high-performance
computing cluster and machine
translation model developers can tap
into the compute power as well as our
existing translation models powered by
Windows Azure this web accessible
service uses the standard Microsoft
translator ap is such as HTTP Ajax
asp.net soap and odata interfaces as
well as a web page embeddable widget the
process for translating from one
language to another can be broken down
into four basic steps setting up a
project uploading the data training a
system to translate from one language to
the other and finally deploying the
system to set up a project the project
owner will need to invite a project
co-owner and reviewers a distinct
advantage of Microsoft translator hub is
that it allows crowdsourcing to help in
the participation of creating
translation models the project owner
will also need a set of documents that
help Microsoft translator hub learn your
language domain and terminology your
next step is to upload your assembled
parallel and monolingual documents
you'll need to set up a training session
so that Microsoft translator hub can
learn how words phrases and sentences
are commonly mapped between the two
languages that you are using more
exposure and immersion in the language
results in a better ability to provide
good translations so the more data you
include and the more active your
community is about submitting
recommended Corrections the better the
system will become as your final step
your translator system can be deployed
for review by your community of language
experts Microsoft translator hub
contributes to cultural and language
preservation
by keeping languages in use we keep them
vibrant and alive for generations to
come
you